[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the various modes of the negative
attitude of consciousness the attitude
of skepticism and that of theoretical
and practical idealism are inferior
shapes compared with that of peer
insight and it's diffusion of the
Enlightenment for pure insight is born
of the substance of spirit knows the
pure self of consciousness to be
absolute and enters into dispute with
the pure consciousness of the absolute
essence of all reality since faith and
insight are the same pure consciousness
but as regards form are opposed the
essence is for faith mere thought not
notion and is therefore the sheer
opposite of self consciousness whereas
for pure insight the essence is the self
their nature is such that each is for
the other the sheer negative of it in
their appearance as mutually opposed all
content falls to faith for each moment
in its tranquil element of thought
obtains an enduring being pure insight
however is in the first instance devoid
of content and is rather the pure
vanishing of it but by the negative
movement towards what is negative to it
it will realize itself and give itself a
content
with paragraph 541 we now begin a
subsection of this enlightenment
subsection and this one is the longer
one it is called the struggle of the
enlightenment with superstition and
superstition is how faith is going to be
framed as we've seen pure insight and
faith are related to each other in an
almost fraternal rivalry they they
cannot escape from each other and pure
insight is going to have to frame faith
in a way that in a certain sense is
alien to faith but is also coming out of
faith that it's very well worth keeping
in mind if you haven't read much in you
know say Christian thought whether in
early Christianity or in medieval
Christianity you will see a lot of
discussions of the difference between
what is viewed as genuine faith or
genuine religion and superstition on the
other hand Christianity originally
framed itself in opposition as did
Judaism to other religious attitudes or
religious perspectives and in a certain
sense it's been talked about as the
DeMuth ologies illegitimate is going to
turn that against faith itself and
specifically christian faith by
construing that as also being a mode of
superstition before we get to that we
have to see what Hegel is is starting
out with here and he's going to draw a
very important contrast as so often when
he begins he likes to you know look back
over how far we have come and what we
have been looking at that that resembled
what we're we're engaging with now and
when it comes to this as he's calling it
negative attitude which is what pure
insight at first is going to be a
negative attitude there are several
different things that he says we've
already passed through and they were
important you know and you might say
going up the ladder to use one of the
metaphors that a commentator of Hegel
who some people keep mentioning to me
brings up you know the
this notion of a ladder what are the
ones that he discusses so we have
skepticism which you may remember from
the self-consciousness section it's
exceeded stoicism and the dialectic of
master and slave and the struggle to the
death and it precedes the unhappy
consciousness which is where we see a
religious attitude taking shape there
the religious attitude is happening
after it is the the dialectical advance
past scepticism it's not one that
actually succeeds the unhappy
consciousness but it is one nonetheless
that that leads us somewhere so Hegel
saying listen this is similar to what is
going on in scepticism but it's not
exactly the same then he brings up and
this is very interesting theoretical and
practical idealism
now of course Hegel is himself an
idealist but not idealists are all on
the same page with each other just
because say Berkeley is an idealist or
you know according to Kant Descartes is
an idealist does not mean that Hegel
sees things the same way that they do
and it may in fact strike you as
something a bit strange to talk about
practical idealism and that's something
we should linger over for just a moment
but first what is he actually talking
about well what went on in the reason
section if you remember we began that
section which correspondent historically
at the beginning too we might say the
Renaissance and the revival of science
in in you know the modern period he said
that reason realized that everything is
for it that everything is for
consciousness that that in in theory at
least everything out there in the world
is knowable understandable that is one
way of understanding idealism in the way
that the the philosophy means it not in
the sense of you know pie-in-the-sky
starry-eyed you know devotion to some
sort of cause
even practical idealism isn't that it's
not just the sitting back and and you
know not engaging with the real world
practical idealism for Hegel as we saw
in the other parts of the reason section
once we got past the physiognomies and
phrenology and we're focusing on the
human being and we're looking at how it
is that that human beings actually try
to realize what we saw as the Jacques
ELPS the the project the ASET the
essential thing and attains some sort of
recognition of who they are and what
they are in the process that is
practical idealism so all these things
like virtue in the way of the world or
you know the law of the heart and frenzy
of self conceit or reason giving itself
laws and and even discovering laws all
of that was what he's calling practical
idealism that is important but that has
also been surpassed
so he tells us that what's different
here he says these are inferior shapes
these are inferior forms that doesn't
mean that they're terrible it just means
that they've been surpassed compared
with that of pure insight and it's
diffusion the Enlightenment pure insight
is born of the substance of spirit and
knows the pure self of consciousness to
be absolute and enters into dispute with
the pure consciousness of the absolute
essence of all reality now it enters
into dispute with what faith it doesn't
just enter into dispute with culture
with the political system with values it
enters into conflict with faith because
faith itself is something very important
for Hegel faith is a mode of pure
consciousness that that is thought it's
not just a feeling it's not just a set
of you know propositions or something
like that it is a shape of consciousness
for Hegel so he says since faith and
insight are the same pure self
consciousness as regards form they're
opposed for s the essences for faith
mere thought not notion
so the enlightenment the diffusion of
pure insight is in significant part an
attempt to take what over here is mere
thought which isn't you know bad by
itself and turn it into notion it turned
it into but turn it in something that is
genuinely self conscious as well as
conscious of something other than it so
he says the thought of faith is the
sheer opposite of self consciousness but
pure insight the essence is the self
their nature is such that each is for
the other the sheer negative of it he
says so he talks about an opposition
here says in their appearances mutually
opposed as they come on the scene
historically is mutually opposed and as
the Enlightenment starts to gain ground
it says all content falls to faith faith
has a wealth of content as we're going
to see in the next paragraph but that
content is going to be critiqued it's
going to be attacked from the position
of the negative and really no defense
that it can mount is really going to
save it from that because the negative
that you can find everywhere so he says
each moment in its tranquil element of
thought obtains an enduring being pure
insight however is in the first instance
devoid of content and is rather the pure
vanishing of it it takes content and it
chews it up and it digests it and when
it's done there's nothing left over so
he says now here's where it gets really
important by the negative movement
towards what is negative to it it will
realize itself and give itself a content
pure insight if it were just pure
insight by itself it would be something
like skepticism because it is this
movement of the Enlightenment within
culture it is going to attain a content
this is a very important point
it knows that faith
as opposed to pure insight opposed to
reason and truth just as it sees faith
in general to be a tissue of
superstitions prejudices and errors so
it further sees the consciousness of
this content organized into a realm of
error in which false insight common to
the mass of people is immediate naive
and unreflective but also it has within
at the moment of reflection into self or
of self consciousness separated from its
naivete in the shape of an insight which
remains independently in the background
and an evil intention by which the
general mass of the people is befooled
the masses are the victims of the
deception of a priesthood which in its
envious conceit holds itself to be the
sole possessor of insight and pursues
its own selfish ends as well at the same
time it conspires with despotism which
as the synthetic non notional unity of
the real and this ideal realm a
curiously inconsistent entity stands
above the bad insight of the multitude
and the bad intentions of the priest and
yet unites both within itself from the
stupidity and confusion of the people
brought about by the trickery of priests
craft despotism which despises both
draws for itself the advantage of
undisturbed domination and the
fulfillment of its desires and caprices
but is itself at the same time the same
dullness of insight the same
superstition and error
in paragraph 542
Hegel is sketching out for us the way
that the Enlightenment and indeed pure
insight historically construes faith on
on its side and there's a number of
different important elements to this you
notice that there's a search type are
tight association or dynamic that Hegel
is going to pick out and talk about here
and in the the coming paragraphs
involving despotism a priesthood and a
rather stupid and ignorant and gullible
people
this is not what Hegel himself is saying
this is what Hegel is saying the
Enlightenment says about social dynamics
and the the entire social sphere this is
what he's saying the Enlightenment
engages in as its critique of religious
institutions and associated with them
political institutions and you might say
a lack of education or formation a lack
of culture on the part of the ordinary
person
so he says pure insight knows that faith
is opposed to it opposed he says to
reason and truth which pure insight is
arrogating to itself and saying we are
the ones who actually are exercising
reason we are the ones who actually do
have truth even if we don't have a
content for that truth yet we at least
are the ones who are seeking truth
rather than claiming that we have truth
and he says it construes faith as a
tissue of superstitions prejudices and
errors and then he says going beyond
this it doesn't just view the person of
faith as you know this isolated
individual who's gotten things wrong but
could be led back to the right way
no it infects the entirety of society
and you might say if we adopt a
historical point of view it represents a
history of errors prior to its own
advent the advent of the Enlightenment
so he says it sees the consciousness of
this content organized into a realm of
error
and notice what he's going to say here
very very important point in which false
insight it's not just that faith has
something to teach and that people
uncritically you know without
questioning it assume it I mean that's
not even really the case in medieval
times in ancient times anyway there's
always people who are saying well wait a
second what about this and but put all
that aside let's say we go with this
caricature faith goes beyond that
because it presents itself as providing
insight you know you might think for
example of the difference between faith
and philosophy or religion and
philosophy or theology and philosophy
notice that you can substitute all these
terms in there because they all get
muddled up together when we look at the
history of this it's very common in
histories of philosophy to say that well
you know with Thomas Aquinas we finally
had a strong distinction between
theology and philosophy that's actually
bunk as far as history of ideas goes the
history is actually much more
complicated rather there are constant
border crossings and sometimes they
weren't even sure that the border was
there the you know medievals talked
about the philosophy of saint benedict
to mean the monastic rule and in the way
of living christian philosophy was
understood in a number of different ways
and with the Enlightenment we have
people saying oh that's not philosophy
that's that's not reason that's just
whatever it is that you happen to
believe Gus eing itself up within the
trappings of rationality rationality
falls on this side so it's really within
the modern period that we find a rigid
distinction between philosophy and faith
starting to be developed at least on the
side of philosophy there certainly was
one on the side of faith you think about
Peter Damien who saw a philosophy is
that you know a tool of the devil but he
also saw a grammar that way as well and
those people are at the extreme
least in the West so going back to this
a realm of air in which false insight
and he says common to the mass of the
people not just the intellectuals the
people think that they have insight and
they're totally wrong about this again
Enlightenment viewpoint Hegel himself is
not actually saying this although Hegel
would have no problem saying it for
different reasons
it's the Enlightenment philosophers who
are saying the people are stupid the
people don't know anything the people
are just sort of an inert mass or even
worse once they start getting ideas the
idea is that they have a really
cockamamie so he goes on and he says
this false insight is immediate naive
and unreflecting and so we have you know
say for example religious devotions
people saying oh I saw Mary or you know
the rise of effective spirituality all
of these sorts of things that we can
point to if we know the history of ideas
and where it coincides with religious
practices which by the way is not that
distant from Hegel we're again remember
Hegel is writing at a time in the
Enlightenment in a certain sense is over
but in a certain sense hasn't already
seen itself through to the end he's part
of an Enlightenment a second
enlightenment we might say so going on
he says the masses are the victims of
the deception here we get the second
term of a priesthood which in its
envious conceit holds itself to be the
sole possessor of insight and pursues
its own selfish ends as well so we have
the institution of a religious hierarchy
and a whole set of orders we can might
think of you know in medieval Europe
priests monks nuns bishops all sorts of
auxiliaries that you know we don't
really have around too much today except
in very special churches like canons and
all of that and they're teaching the
people but they're deceiving them and
they're doing it to their own benefit
but they're also doing it because they
themselves are to see
about their own role and they're
teaching the people superstition the
people themselves already have plenty of
superstition going for them but the
priests shape it the priests you know
modify it so we might think for example
of you know how Christianity ended up
taking over Europe and replacing the
various pagan customs you know we see
for example Gregory the Great telling I
think it's Austin this is mentioning in
beads history of England that you know
the pagan temples should be instead of
being destroyed rededicate them to the
true God right and so you can take the
superstitions of the people already
there and turn them around make them
serve some sort of Christian purposes
make them serve the faith now Hegel says
that you know the Enlightenment sees
this as the realm of error spreading
itself so he says here we go the masses
are the victim of a deception of the
priesthood at the same time this
priesthood conspires with a despotism a
political rule right we might think of
Kings we might think of whoever happens
to be in charge in feudal Europe or in
you know early modern Europe we have all
these principalities spread throughout
Germany and Italy and and some other
places as well even in organized
nation-states like like you know rising
Great Britain or France or Spain you do
have these Nobles who are in charge and
they work hand in hand with the
priesthood the priesthood helps to keep
the peasants and the city dwellers in
line despotism allows rule over them it
works out very well for both Zooey says
it conspires with this despotism which
as the synthetic non notional unity of
the real and this ideal realm the
despotism what is he talking about there
something like you know Kings and other
people being seen as in a semi way in
some way divine
right you could think of what happened
in the Protestant Reformation already
the Kings had a semi-divine status
before that when Henry the eighth makes
the King the head of the church that in
a certain way consolidates these
religious energies that are available
available particularly through the
closing of the monasteries and taking
over all of these these dimensa-zam
domains so he says this is a curiously
inconsistent entity and it stands above
the bad insight of the multitude and the
bad intentions of the priests and yet
unites both within itself so we're
talking about despotism being able to in
a certain way
harness faith and now we're talking
about state power again right so what
goes on he says from the stupidity and
confusion of the people brought about by
the trickery of priesthood despotism now
notice this which despises both draws
for itself the advantage of undisturbed
domination and the fulfillment of its
desires and caprices but it is itself at
the same time the same dullness of
insight the same superstition and error
that is everything the Enlightenment is
supposed to be fighting against those
are the three key things stupid
superstitious people you know grafting
greedy hypocritical priests and a
despotism which looks on all of this and
says you stupid fools I can use you now
to enforce a kind of social order that's
going to work out for me I'm not really
the defender of the faith and I'm not
really the warden of the people but I'll
treat myself as such so long as you're
going to keep calling me that that is
what the Enlightenment opposes itself to
and views as opposed to it
the Enlightenment does not attack these
three aspects of the enemy without
making a distinction for since its
essence is pure insight what is
universal in and for itself its true
relation to the other extreme is that in
which it concerns itself with a common
and identical element in both the aspect
of individuality isolating itself from
the general naive consciousness is its
antithesis which it cannot directly
affect the will of the deceiving
priesthood and of the oppressive despot
is therefore not directly the object of
its activity its object as the insight
devoid of will which has no separable
individuality of its own the notion of
rational self-consciousness which has
its existence in the general mass but is
not yet present there kua notion pure
insight however in delivering this
honest insight and it's essentially
naive nature from prejudices and errors
rests from the hands of the bad
intention the reality and power of its
deceit for whose realm the naive
consciousness of the general mass of the
people provides its basis and material
that is the being for self of that realm
has its substance in the simple naive
consciousness as such
Hegel begins paragraph 543 now having
identified these these three aspects of
the enemy by saying that the
Enlightenment does not attack these or
engage in critique without making a
distinction what is the distinction is
he talking about distinguishing between
them you know saying well the despotism
is something different than the
priesthood is something different than
the superstitious people so we have to
adopt say different modes of attack for
each of those that is not what he is
actually saying here he's talking about
something different which is going to be
isolating out a common element not just
a common element to each of these but a
common element between pure insight and
the entire realm of faith is tissue of
superstitions errors and deceptions so
he says because its essence is pure
insight what is universal in and for
itself it's true relation to the other
extreme as that in which it concerns
itself with a common an identical
element in in both what is common and
identical and both of these here he
talks about individuality so we have the
universal as involving the individual
and we've seen that you know that there
really is no absolute contradiction
between these and Hegelian dialectics
how is that going to play itself out
here he says the the aspect of
individuality isolating itself from the
general naive consciousness is its
antithesis which it cannot directly
affect so we're not going to be looking
at just individuality per se the
individuality of a contingent being he
says the will of the deceiving
priesthood and of the oppressive despot
is therefore not directly the object of
its activity in a way these are
individuals right the despot you can
appeal to them as an individual or you
can critique them as an individual ah
the king is a jerk right these this
is engaging in these hypocritical
practices look how deceptive they are I
mean imagine if the internet had been
around and and cameras at the time of
the Enlightenment we'd have all these
revelations be going on of how terrible
everybody is the way we do today so he
says that's not what the Enlightenment
is actually going to focus on I mean it
will actually focus on that a lot but
that's not where the the thrust the the
critical strength of it lies he says the
object is the insight devoid of will
which has no separable individuality of
its own the notion of rational
self-consciousness which has its
existence in the general mass but is not
yet present there kua notion everybody
on this side is also rational
self-consciousness but they're not
behaving rationally in a self-conscious
way you might say that they're there
they're employing what what should be
rational self-consciousness in a way
that is irrational they're using their
rationality to deny that rationality
they are being less self-conscious than
they ought to be if we wanted to frame
this in terms of freedom which is not
talking about here but would make a
sense to talk about it we could say
they're using their freedom to throw
away their freedom and this is a point
of history where that could in fact be
changed not just for particular
individuals not just get rid of this
despot and bring in a new boss not just
you know call out the bad priests and
have some some you know devout ones in
there but rather change across the board
so he says pure insight in delivering
this honest insight and it's essentially
naive nature from prejudices and errors
as it's deriving this this from over
here
this essentially naive nature taking it
away wrest from the hands of the bad
intention the reality and power of its
deceit what does that mean it rests from
the hands of the bad intention the bad
intention was on the part of the priests
the reality and power of its deceit it's
offering an alternative it's satisfying
the naive consciousness which otherwise
would be listening to the priesthood
with something better
he says for whose realm the naive
consciousness of the general mass of the
people provides its basis and material
the simple the being for itself of that
realm has its substance in the simple
naive consciousness of such the
enlightenment is going to be appealing
to the common man to the ordinary person
and saying listen the stuff that these
guys are telling you to really look at
it doesn't actually make sense now does
it let's apply reason here that is at
the core of what enlightenment critique
is about
you